regardez pour la première fois les
catégories n'était pas genre est finie
les catégories artiste féminine ou
artiste masculin adele a été sacré
simplement artiste de l'année tout est
parti d'une remarque de l'artiste sam
smith l'année dernière qui se revendique
non binaire j'attends avec impatience d
est il une époque où les remises de prix
pourront refléter la société dans
laquelle nous vivons ni une ni deux en
novembre dernier les organisateurs des
brit awards déclaré vouloir désormais
célébrer les artistes uniquement pour
leur musique et leur travail alors c'est
aussi un problème plus global puisque la
cérémonie est accusé de sexisme sur dix
ans 70% des artistes nommés dans les
grandes catégories étaient des hommes
alors est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça gilles verdez oui bien entendu on va
prendre tout de suite le boulet après on
verra les aureilhanais 2 1 les deux
cellulaires et pis
alors allez-y enfin bravo les brit
awards depuis le temps que j'attendais
ça on va parler de travail on va pas
parler de la manière dont les gens sont
perçus on va pas parler de savoir si
c'est un homme une femme non c'est tout
ce qu'ils font c'est génial de l'année
dernière sam smith que vous adorez dans
stan smith inertie il n'était pas les
laver celui qui fait des baskets il
n'était pas allé là bas et là enfin il
va pouvoir y aller j'attendais ça depuis
très longtemps je suis vraiment nous
allons parler formidable mais ce mec
mahut
sénat il occupe le lycée c'est sam smith
qui est notamment à l'origine de ça
parce qu'il s'était plaint réalisant
qu'il ne pouvait pas y aller a oui voilà
mais je pense que gilles encore une fois
je te le redis l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions c'est à dire que
encore une fois tu imagines que ça va
résoudre tous les problèmes qui se
balançait avait causé du moulin ça va
pas résoudre les problèmes et par
ailleurs ça peut même être
contre-productive parce que tout ce qui
va se passer il va y avoir des hommes et
des femmes et tu vas voir que comme par
hasard ça va être raflés par que des
mecs et y aura pas de filles où il y
aura très peu de chinois ou bien ils
vont faire au match et ils ont péri en
fait non ce qu'ils vont faire l'om on a
donné deux fois des mais il faut pas une
soirée dj retards et à
son aura dans la catégorie des amis y
aura des jeunes de talent et pendant
vraiment d'accord avec talent il a
changé non mais je te jure ce que ça va
devenir on l'a bien ça va dire c'est
quoi serrières attendez on l'a donnée de
faire ensuite deux fils on va le voir le
donnait un mec mais voilà c'est une
grotesque évidement vous envisager
l'avenir tous je
vous ai vu à gimeux pee wee gérald jour
merizzi total c'est là comme à la mode
ou au christ est évidemment tu tombe
dans le panneau parce que tu es sûre est
alors en plus
en plus ignorer ni du sort donc en fait
on fait une catégorie non j'aurai à dell
gagne magnifique interprète elle fait un
discours et qu'est ce qu'elle dit je
suis heureuse et très vite je suis
heureux d'être une femme je suis fière
d'être une artiste film adèle en fait
voilà donc en fait elle fait une feinte
est fait un discours après hyper
féministe et hyper jean raibaut marque
en fait c'est ridicule alors oui on est
tout à fait vrai manque à changer d'avis
oui moi de là tu m'appelles 5e du
continent c'est un peu c'est un peu dur
de j'aime bien quand j'ai mes
convictions et là comme tu as réussi à
m'adapter
mais maintenant tout à fait en fait
évoluer il faut évoluer que la société
ça nous paraît ridicule aujourd'hui je
pense que dans votre voiture ça fait
partie de l'évolution
nous paraît ridicule je pense que dans
20 ans tout le monde trouvera ça normal
nous sommes dans le score ça juste ans
de séparer les hommes des femmes quoi
c'est sexiste non pas du tout parce que
c'est pour décrire la deuxième entité si
bien voilà ce qui dans la musique ça n'a
aucun sens à
la raison à la raison un artiste est un
artiste peu importe que ce soit un homme
ou une femme et puis à cette
problématique des artistes on est de
plus en plus qui se sentent non genre et
il faut les représentait donc ça
pourquoi c'est un changement bah oui
c'est la
réponse voleurs à nice tu me plaît je
dois répondre aux leurs vous allez me
oui oui tout à fait mais oui je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec guillaume et
avec green 1 mondial a
allégé au caire où le débat pourquoi est
ce qu ont séparé les hommes des femmes
si on verrait si véritablement bon c'est
vrai que ça fera moins de prix il n'y
aura pas un prix pour un homme et un
prix pour les femmes mais bon ça encore
je pense qu'au contraire il faut lutter
contre cette discrimination positive on
part du principe y aura une
discrimination positive mais au compteur
il faut changer les mentalités c'est
exactement ce que vient de dire gagner
votre secret si véritablement on va les
faire quel âge et savoir 3e mais peut
créer une catégorie pour les transgenres
ou pour les personnes qui ne veulent pas
s'assimiler ni un homme et une femme
sort et d une troisième solution voilà
oui
éventuels frais d'une troisième
catégorie mais oui séparé les hommes et
oran est pas la solution mais on est au
prix uniforme et ou bowie enfermé outre
jamais posé aucun problème en fait j'ai
pas envie de gitega pancartes parce que
moi mon discours par rapport à ça c'est
que suis assez d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire j il faut faire avancer la
société moi je suis une génération tout
ça ne trouble un peu le i le yale le
machin et je pense honnêtement il ya
plein de gens voient la salle et qui me
font comme ça bah ouais on n'est pas
habitués savent pas où ça bouge fort et
je trouve que ça que tu as aussi une
cassure chez des gens qui ont pas envie
de ce monde là et il faut peut-être
temps pour leur expliquer et tout d'un
coup pourquoi on arrête miss france et
ont fait un concours avec des mecs et
des heures sur tf1 allez la grand mère
qui a mangé le petit chaperon
je ça paraît un bon principe est à la
fois non mais tu en as accès à l'eau
sinon vous dites mais oui il faut
s'habituer faut vivre avec son temps
culte ans et à quoi il faut s'habituer
benoît qui faisait aux hommes ont d'être
désormais fameuse ronde est des fans et
faire une unification mais
jamais les clivages j'avais désolé ça va
aggraver to believe âge alors glace
malgré qu'il soit donc pour les oscars
et césars ont fait une catégorie
meilleur acteur presse ont fait en faire
un truc on mélange les gars ont été
très dures et le meilleur possible bien
sûr source qui source kahn a dit qu'il
aura lie singler alice pourquoi ce
cadavre salami chaque fois il faut qu on
retranche des choses pourquoi ce qu'il
faut pas mal et on ajoute pourquoi je
peux effectivement pourquoi match on
ajouterait pas une nouvelle catégorie
une catégorie il se reconnaît ni chez
les hommes et chez les femmes socoda de
d'annihiler et de dire il n'y a pas de
différences
voyez que siens non parce que le propre
du nom genre et c'est dire que on peut
se sentir ni homme ni femme c'est le
chroniqueur au chroniqueuse mais
c'est pas parce que ça ne vous concerne
pas vous que c'est pas important il ya
des gens qui se sont chargés aujourd'hui
il ya peut-être des artistes féminines
qui ont en effet durement mardi
considérer uniquement en tant que femme
et qui veulent être considérés en tant
qu'artiste je vous souhaite une très
bonne aussi je veux faire ça je veux
faire que le meilleur gagne que ce soit
un homme ou une femme n'y a pas vraiment
de performance finale moi aussi je veux
faire comme tu dis mais ce qu'il a dit
un jour une année on l'a donné à une
femme dont on parlera de l'année
prochaine
la série les valérie oui c'est tout à
fait digéré les valérie c'est céline
valerie jarrett
on